ce fameux débarquement en normandie
finalement été déterminant pour les
alliés oui hazeb évidemment un tel
débarquement avec autant de jeunes gens
qui vont défendre l'europe au péril de
leur vie
ça se planifie bien sûr longtemps à
l'avancé donc en 1943 à washington se
sont réunis
messieurs roosevelt et churchill pour
planifier justement ce fameux
débarquement l'idée c'est de donner un
coup de main aussi aux russes qui eux
demandent qu'on ouvre un front dans
l'ouest pour chasser les allemands bien
sûr et chasser les troupes nazies de
adolf hitler alors ce qui va se passer
c'est que on va essayer de créer un
effet de surprise alors les allemands y
pense dans le fond que le lien
débarquement qui se préparent ils savent
que quelque chose se tramait ce 10 mai
ça va probablement se passer ici dans la
région du pas de calais dans le nord de
la france où près de la belgique parce
que c'est plus proche de l'allemagne est
d'ailleurs les alliés vont leur faire
croire la même chose puisqu'en face de
calais ils vont construire des avions en
carton en bois également des chars
d'assaut gonflable pour leur faire
croire qu'effectivement on se prépare à
envahir
or ce n'est pas du tout ce qui va se
passer puisque en fait c'est bel et bien
ici en normandie que va se planifier ce
fameux débarquement et donc pendant des
semaines les alliés vont en quelque
sorte faire des exercices donc on va
essayer de de voir comment on déploie
toute cette armada tous ses soldats
on va même pensé à construire un
pipeline sous-marin qui permettra
d'alimenter en carburant en fait les
nombreux véhicules qui vont débarquer le
6 juin 1944 alors cette fameuse
opération
eh bien on va l'appeler l'opération
overlord et là on va donner aux
américains aux britanniques et aux
canadiens aux canadiens donc une place
particulière les canadiens ne vont
hériter de la fameuse plage de juno
alors bien sûr c'est une bataille qui
s'annonce assez féroce le débarquement
commence et pour toutes cette bataille
aura cent cinquante six mille soldats
qui vont être mobilisés parmi lesquels
59000 américain il y aura également
73000 britannique et bien sûr 21400
canadiens et ce fameux jour du 6 juin
et bien il y aura pas moins de quatorze
mille canadiens dont notamment des
canadiens français qui font partie des
fusiliers mont royal régiment de
maisonneuve et régiment de la chaudière
ce sera évidemment une campagne
particulièrement difficiles il y aura
mille victimes alliés blessés et tués du
côté du canada il y aura 350 notre
personnes qui vont tomber au front
évidemment pour les allemands c'est le
début de la fin la savait pas comment
c'est évidemment le point tournant de
toute cette guerre puisque bon
énormément de soldats allemands vont
mourir vont être faits prisonniers
les russes également vont réussir à le
repousser sur du côté de l'europe de
l'est et tout ça bien sûr va conduire à
la libération de paris la libération de
la france dans les semaines qui vont
suivre
merci beaucoup frédéric